For all first-flight pilots I'll now explain turn flying to you.
At the beginning we fly out. What's always important after take-off is first to keep direction, come out straight.
Flying straight away from the slope is for us first of all the most important thing.
And as soon as we're away from the slope, we can try to climb into the harness, pull the knees up and wiggle the bum.
If that's not enough, then we push ourselves back here into the harness so that we sit in there as comfortably as possible, as is the case with me now.
Then on every turn always look in the direction of the airspace first. Can I turn to that side?
Is it clear? So I don't initiate a turn and fly straight into someone else's canopy.
That's always decisive. So look, airspace clear.
And before we now work with the brake, always first put weight on that side.
And you see, with seat board this works very well.
Whoever has their legs free can put the left leg over the right and get even more weight shift that way.
And only then do we take the brake along to support.
Work slowly with the brake; if he feels it could be a bit more, or I'll also say, pull another 3 cm, may be another 3 cm.
Exit always neutral, sit in the harness, and I really announce everything to you — that is, you start normally braked on both sides.
Look to the turn side, weight, and then one brake comes more, the other maybe even goes a bit up.
I'll announce all of that to you, and exit by first bringing the weight back to neutral and then braking the outer side,
so that you always come out braked out of any braking.
That means that the turns or dynamic build-ups come out.